Spain is holding a minute of silence to
pay tribute to the victims of koban 19
[Music]
[Music]
this is the King Felipe there in royal
family marking this minute of silence a
solemn moment there in Spain paying
tribute to the more than 27,000 victims
who died in the country from the
coronavirus
and here is the Spanish Parliament also
taking part in this minute of Silas
here we are seeing people around the
country taking part in the ceremony
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna give this is at the
beginning of a 10-day mourning period
that the government has declared there
in Spain to honor the 27 thousand people
have died from kovat 19 and our reporter
young Philip Schultz is in Spain they're
witnessing this ceremony yeah what is
this moment what is this meant to Spain
and how is a country trying to look
ahead veinous a traumatized country at
the moment the pictures of overcrowded
hospitals of patients begging for help
are still very fresh in the collective
memory of the people and my impression
is that it will still take a very long
time for those wounds to heal to heal
and I think two things make it worse at
the moment
Spain is a very divided country when it
comes to politics the right-wing
opposition is strongly criticizing the
management of the crisis by the
left-wing government and the economic
predictions are getting worse and worse
every day several millions of Spaniards
have already lost their job so the big
hope at the moment is that there will
still be some kind of summer holiday
season here in Spain which is a very big
economic factor for the country but this
is not sure yet this will actually take
place this year all right we see ya
people clapping there as part of the
ceremony flags and public buildings
around the country flying at half-mast
we saw a little bit earlier king of
Felipe presiding over the ceremony that
minute of silence in Spain and our
reporter just talking to their young
Philip Schultz thank you young Philip as
Spain honors the victims 27,000 victims
of copán 19 international donors have
pledged over 3 billion euros to support
refugees and migrants from Venezuela as
the corona virus pandemic worsens their
plight more than 5 million Venezuelans
have fled the economic chaos under
president Nicolas Maduro here's the
story of one of those exiles
it's a job no one else wants to do
grueling dangerous work recovering
bodies of kovat 19 victims Joanne finita
used to work as an electrician in his
native Venezuela before he migrated to
Peru two years ago to escape the dire
economic crisis back home in his new job
he and his fellow workers from the Pedro
Angle funeral home collect as many as
ten bodies a day more than 400 since
March here they are picking up the body
of a man who committed suicide because
he couldn't get treatment after testing
positive for the virus
Johan always worries the dangerous work
he has to do might end up harming his
family before returning home he always
showers and washes his clothes with
disinfectant sometimes he gargles with
salt water I'm always afraid afraid to
infect my family when they go back home
to my children but it's something that
has to be faced and I have to continue
working to put food on the table Peru
has over 108,000 confirmed kovat 19
cases in over 3,000 deaths the second
hardest hit country in Latin America
after Brazil the current lockdown
conditions are making it even harder for
the estimated 850,000 Venezuelan
migrants in Peru to make ends meet
Juwan has to keep working and hoping
he'll stay healthy for his family
including his elderly parents who
remained in Venezuela and let's take a
look now at some of today's other
coronavirus developments the number of
people who have died of Cova 19s
surpassed 350,000 that's according to
Johns Hopkins University in the US and
the United States accounts for about a
third of those deaths Thailand has
extended its state of emergency laws for
another month until the end of June the
government says the laws are still
needed as the country gradually eases
restrictions India's top biomedical
research body has backed the use of the
anti malaria drug hydroxychloroquine as
a treatment for corona virus this comes
after the w-h-o suspended its trial of
the drug citing safety concerns Greek
doctors are visiting the country's
islands to test residents for Kovan 19
they are hoping to bolster testing
capabilities there before tourists are
to arrive
begin Greece will begin to open up its
borders to international travelers on
June 15th like Germany Japan has emerged
from coronavirus lockdown with a
relatively low toll on public health but
economy has taken a big hit the EU and
Japan pledged to work more closely in
restarting cross-border trade in goods
and services that will come as music to
the ears of businesses in Japan Japan
has had some of the world's most relaxed
lockdown measures it was not until the
7th of April that Japan declared a state
of emergency the government didn't even
enforce a general lockdown citizens were
only asked to stay at home this week
shops opened again even for many
Japanese Japan is moving too quickly
I think lifting emergency measures came
a bit early but many won't survive if
companies and shops don't reopen fast
[Music]
the AH Bay government is in a hurry
although the corona virus pandemic in
Japan has been relatively mild with only
850 deaths it has caused the world's
third-largest economy to slide into a
recession in the first quarter you know
the looking at the GDP data from January
to March we think the corona virus
measures such as social distancing had
an impact on the public in the second
quarter the damage from the kavod crisis
will worsen experts expect an economic
slump of 20 to 30 percent this year to
get the country back on its feet
Tokyo is implementing whopping stimulus
packages worth nearly two trillion
dollars but the Japanese are no
strangers to stimulus packages and there
are questions whether the world's most
indebted country can afford that kind of
spending
European fishermen are used to
weathering all sorts of storms but the
corona virus pandemic is a new one fish
markets and seafood restaurants are shut
down supply chains are broken and large
vessels are anchored in harbors
thousands of fishermen are at risk of
losing their jobs
normally this part of the Mediterranean
Sea off the coast of France is busy with
boat and yacht traffic but the seas are
quieter than usual and that's a problem
for many small-scale fishermen in this
area April to June are their most
important months while normal orders
have dried up
some fishermen are turning to a service
familiar to many home delivery our usual
clients are restaurants and we lost them
due to the shutdown the remaining
customers are private citizens so we
have to start delivering fish to most of
them we fish in the morning and do
deliveries in the afternoon that makes
for long work days thanks to coronavirus
sales are down by half but these
fishermen say deliveries on the phone
are helping them stay afloat I have some
nice ones weighing around 700 grams
maybe a kilo and have some smaller ones
too from the docks to your door that's
the service these fishermen are now
providing as big buyers like restaurants
and caterers remain closed for business
but the same people catching the fish
are also making the deliveries workdays
can last from 4 a.m. to 9 p.m. in the
town of Antibes fishermen now have
permission to sell their catches
directly in Port for fishermen that have
to wait out this storm longer-term there
are some EU aid measures but these
locals say they prefer to work as much
as possible while keeping necessary
precautions in place
in some parts of the Mediterranean and
Black Sea more than 90% of fishing boats
have already stopped operating meanwhile
in Antibes and elsewhere along the
European coast fishermen are trying
their best to keep working